spinal care of nevada who is the sponsor
of this next segment offers complete
chiropractic care here to tell us more
about their gentle form of care is dr
devin welcome back to the show my friend
thanks for having me let's start with
what is new what is nuka so if you've
been to chiropractic or if you're afraid
to go and you did the twist and pop and
crack nuka is an alternative to the more
forceful chiropractic it's a very gentle
adjustment
interestingly enough to the top of the
neck the human head weighs about the
same as a bowling ball and men's heads
are a little thicker than when i see
thicker heavier heavier men's heads are
my wife would tell you that mine is a
little thicker than most
so just imagine this bowling ball tilted
off car accidents work bad posture the
body's going to twist and turn
underneath and cause pain from head to
toe so nuka is a very well measured
gentle adjustment to the top bone gets
the head on straight
so the body can balance underneath now
what is there a certain red flag when it
comes to back pain i'm in the gym i'm
working out lifting some heavy weights i
feel something here yeah i know it's
gonna go in a couple days absolutely is
that a red flag the number one red flag
in a patient's history when you're going
to have a disc problem is pain that
comes and goes over time every time the
pain comes back your spine is getting
weaker more degenerated it's like um if
you take a paper clip did that enough
time yes eventually it's gonna okay so
hopefully we've caught it in time where
it's gonna be okay and not a surgical
conversation yes i see patients who are
scheduled for surgery because what we do
is so gentle
but guys if you're anything like me it's
better to be proactive then wait till
you get into the er right yeah it's it's
great advice now give me a little
demonstration of how it works
so the nuka is a gentle adjustment to
the top of the neck this is called an
arthrostim the kids in my office call it
the woodpecker i love the sound of it
so when a patient has pain down below in
this area also known as the dowager sump
gets a lot bigger the older you get we
can do a gentle adjustment there how
about pain in the middle of back between
your shoulder blades or carpal tunnel
syndrome nerve pain running down the
arms a lot of times that comes from the
neck this can open up the disc and get
pressure off the nerve lower back pain
same thing disc problems hip pain works
amazing on knees i'm really really good
at treating knees and bad shoulders now
when you're working on these are you
going down to the knees you're working
the back to work the knees great
question sometimes knee problems can
come from the hips and low back but also
we work on what's called
scar tissue which is really jumbled up
bad tissue in the knees now you guys do
what i love you can't just walk in and
sit down with you you do a two day
workout a two-day build up what goes
into that process we're not the walk-in
quick crack guys so we're very thorough
on day one we're going to do a thorough
health history a set of exams that have
probably never been done before on the
patient and a set of digital x-rays it's
the most detailed x-rays in my field
from there we're gonna sit and study
them for a day or two the patient comes
back and then on day two we're gonna go
over this chart that you all see on the
tv and it tells us based on where you're
feeling the pain where that nerve runs
back to in the spine so at the very top
of the neck if you have a bone out of
place it can cause headaches migraines
allergies sinus problems even dizziness
balance issues if you have a problem in
the middle of the back again that can
run down your arms so day two
very upfront if we can't help we'll tell
you if we can we'll go over time cost
coverage everything if you're anything
like me you don't want financial
surprises so we're up front love it
thank you so much dr devin we truly
appreciate it and in spinal care of
nevada they have two locations summerlin
and henderson you can reach them at 702
566 hope that's six seven three or go to
drdevin.com the two-day work-up
including digital x-rays for thirty
seven dollars that's normally a hundred
and eighty dollars for the first twenty
callers not valid for those eligible for
federal benefits